bonjour eric alt merci de répondre à nos
questions votre association a donc
déposé hier une plainte à visant eric
dupond-moretti pour prise illégale
d'intérêt auprès de la commission des
requêtes de la cour de justice de la
république sur l'instance habilitée à
juger les ministres pour des délits
commis dans le cadre de leurs fonctions
qu'est ce que vous attendez en termes de
décision en justice eh bien nous
attendons de la commission des requêtes
qu'elle saisisse la commission
d'instruction
car nous pensons que c'est plus qu'un
conflit d'intérêts confit d'intérêt
c'est une interférence entre un intérêt
public il ya un tp privé là c'est
peut-être
il appartiendra à la cour de justice de
dire une prise illégale d'intérêt et
donc c'est un délit je pense que il
n'est pas sain que le garde des sceaux
utilise ses pouvoirs de ministres au
prendre une revanche sur la justice
financière
c'est vrai qu'on se souvient des
l'acquisition du bnf du parquet
financier dans la sphère cahuzac on se
souvient des réquisitions du parquet
financier dans la sphère balkany
évidemment il ya cette affaire de
fadettes mais je pense que c'est un pur
prétexte
le vrai problème du parquet financier
c'est que le parquet financier agace les
puissants agace les avocats des
puissants et aujourd'hui il paye un peu
de cela une paye un peu pour cela des
magistrats se rassemblent pour rédiger
un d'émotion sur le sujet pour leur
ministre de tutelle je cite piétine le
principe démocratique de séparation des
pouvoirs au profit d'intérêts
strictement privé en quoi le garde des
sceaux aurait-il violer ce principe
fondamental est bien le garde des sceaux
avait traité le parquet national
financier de barbouzes il ne supportait
pas que les fadettes donc les
facturations détaillées de téléphone et
était exploité en ce qui le concerne et
en celui concernant un certain nombre
d'autres avocats puisque la question à
l'origine était de savoir s'il y avait
une taupe et
ça semble d'avocats pouvait être la
taupe qui aurait informé nicolas sarkozy
dans une enquête où il était poursuivi
et donc il avait déjà dit que je porte
plainte contre le parquet financier
il a apporté plein qu'il a retiré sa
plainte quand il est devenu ministre
cette plainte a d'ailleurs été classé
hier par le parquet de nanterre mais on
voit bien que healy a dès le départ
avant même qu'ils me soient ministres
une hostilité vis-à-vis du parquet
financier et il n'est pas simple que le
ministre de la justice est une hostilité
envers un parquet d'autres il est quand
même le supérieur hiérarchique même s'il
ne peut pas donner d'ordres dans des
affaires particulières il est le
supérieur hiérarchique de l'ensemble des
procureurs et dont donc du procureur
financier
l'avocat d'anticor jérôme karsenti a
déclaré akira dupond-moretti je cite ne
sert pas la mission qui est la mienne
qu'est ce qu'il veut dire par là il ne
sert pas la mission g ou sept ans de la
part d'un ministre de la justice à ce
qu'il est une certaine neutralité au
regard de des affaires qui sont
instruites
on ne s'attend pas de la part du
ministre de la justice à ce qu'il passe
ou que par exemple il met en scène son
amitié avec un prévenu qui va être
poursuivi par le pénètre dans une
affaire qui sera jugée en novembre
prochain
tiens il s'est affiché en vacances on
l'a vu sur paris match l'affairé zahia
qui assure la défense de l'ex-président
à nicolas sarkozy quand même mettre en
scène dans paris match cette amitié
s'est envoyé un signal
et c'est pas exactement ce qu'on attend
de la part d'un ministre ça ne contribue
pas non plus à la sérénité de la justice
un garde des sceaux qui poursuit le pnf
c'est une première non pour pourquoi le
istres son but il entretient des
relations de défiance avec la
magistrature comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquer alors disons en tant
qu'avocat il a dit ce qu'il pensait
devoir dire pour la défense mais
maintenant il n'est plus avocat il est
ministre et la question se pose pour
louis d'une façon un peu différent et je
ne pense pas qu'il est tout à fait
réaliser qu'il ait pris la mesure de ce
que signifie être un ministre et
s'agissant particulièrement du parti
national financiers je note que dans
l'aspect ctions général de la justice
dans son rapport
les 15 septembre a dit c'est une
institution reconnue institut
internationalement
on y observe une recherche d'excellence
cette institution a permis de recouvrer
7 milliards d'euros
certes il ya des problèmes
d'organisation il ya des problèmes
d'organisation qu'on peut remédier mais
il n'y a pas d'infraction du ontologique
il n'y a pas de problèmes disciplinaires
dans ce dossier avant même que ce
dossier une aiguille été remis il avait
pris la décision de poursuivre trois
magistrats de ce parc
et c'est dans cette instrumentalisation
de l'inspection générale des services
judiciaires qu'il y aura aussi un vrai
problème
et selon la décision que rendra la cour
de justice de la république
est-ce que vous appellerez par la suite
à la démission d'eric dupond-moretti
je veux dire nous attendons d'abord de
voir ce que dira la cour de justice de
la république mais je pense que de
nombreux magistrats est en tout cas les
deux principaux syndicats de magistrats
et c'est un indicateur dallaire cas on
retrouve rarement côte à côte les deux
principaux syndicats de magistrats
ils disent déjà que dupont moretti
devrait de plus s'occuper de la justice
et que c'est le premier ministre qui
devrait le faire pour moretti pourrait
encore s'occuper de l'administration
pénitentiaire et de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse
merci eric alt d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes
magistrats et vice président de
l'association anticorruption anticor qui
portent plainte donc contre eric dupond
moretti